PAUL FREEDMAN: We're
going to talk today, now,
about Carolingian decline.
It's not just that
we're compressing
lectures or in a hurry.
The empire of Charlemagne
is an empire that does
not last that long.
So when we say that it has
certain flaws, like size,
well, we already said that the
Roman Empire had this flaw.
We've already said
that the Abbasid
Caliphate has this flaw.
But those empires are able to
manage with this weakness for
quite some time.
Part of the problem with
the Carolingian
Empire is its size.
Part of it, however, as you
will have read in the
Fichtenau reading is its lack of
infrastructure and economic
development.
Infrastructure in a sense of
not just towns, roads,
communications, but social
infrastructure, the lack of an
idea of obeying the state or
obeying the ruler, and a
tendency, therefore, to mix
private and public interest,
and to the benefit
of the powerful.
We'll talk more about that.
There are also external
problems. The beginnings of
the Viking invasion, which we
will be talking about after
the break, occur before
Charlemagne's death in 814.
Nevertheless, there's
no sense hastening
the signs of decline.
We always can see signs of
decline coming after.
But Charlemagne's rule had been
so successful, so full of
accomplishments, he was a ruler
such prestige, that even
the difficult last ten years or
so of his reign can't quite
eclipse that.
In 801, there arrived an
elephant at the court of
Charlemagne, a gift from the
caliph of Baghdad, Harun
al-Rashid, the caliph who
figures in the Arabian Nights
entertainments.
This is a link between two very
powerful and very distant
empires, the two of the three
that we've described as, in
some sense, heirs to the Roman
classical empire and
civilization.
There was a tentative thought
of, perhaps, an alliance
between Baghdad and Aachen,
the capital of
Charlemagne's empire.
At various times, there had
been negotiations between
Constantinople and Aachen
discussing the possibility of
an imperial marriage.
The Carolingian ruler was
contemptuous of Byzantium
because it was ruled by a woman,
the Empress Irene, a
rather exceptional figure.
But neither the alliance with
Byzantium, at least not at
this point, and certainly not
the more far-fetched alliance
with Baghdad came to anything.
The elephant was certainly the
first one seen in Europe
probably since Hannibal and
his invasion of Italy.
And how he got there, what the
logistics of his transport
were, how he got to Baghdad in
the first place-- it's not as
if they have elephants
in the natural
habitat of Iraq either.
Nevertheless, here's this
elephant who lives
for about ten years.
One of the signs of things
starting to unravel in the
Carolingian Empire, so some
historians say, is the death
of Charlemagne's elephant, which
Einhard talks about,
actually, in his biography; that
is, it is an event that's
worth mentioning.
But pets, they don't
last forever.
As someone who lost his cat
within recent memory, you've
just got to get over it.
On the other hand, I can
get another cat.
And Charlemagne, presumably--
well, not presumably.
We know he didn't get
another elephant.
The high watermark of
his reign seems
to be the year 802.
This is arbitrary, but this is
shown by the energy of his
quarrel with the Byzantine
empress over his arrogating to
himself the title of emperor.
This is the first person in
the West claiming to be
emperor, and the Byzantine
Empire doesn't like it.
By 802, he is done with his two
campaigns; one in Spain,
and the other in Saxony and
the regions of the Danube.
He had pacified the
Saxons after a
nearly twenty-year effort.
And while he hadn't achieved his
ambitions in Spain, he had
seized territory in
the northern part
of what's now Catalonia.
He attempted to address the
problem that I've just
identified, namely the tendency
of powerful people to
take over and rule localities
not as government servants,
but as noble rulers.
He, in order to combat that,
tried to get every free man in
his realm to swear an oath to
him personally, that is to
make sure that they understood
that their prime loyalty had
to be to the emperor and not
to the count, duke, local
ruler, bishop, whoever he was.
And the instructions that he
gave to the men sent out to
try and to administer this oath
show you some of his idea
of rulership.
We've talked about this already,
but since it's a
fairly complex idea, it's
worth emphasizing.
In the instructions, it says,
"Let each man keep himself in
the sacred service of God,
following the divine
commandment and observing
whatever promise he may have
made fully, to the best of his
understanding and powers.
For the lord emperor cannot
exercise his vigilance or
powers of correction over every
man." So the notion that
the emperor is supposed to
be responsible for people
behaving themselves, is
responsible for not just what
we would call political order,
or peace, but for the
salvation of the people, for
the spiritual as well as
political health of the realm,
is typically Carolingian, and,
in a way, typically medieval.
There's a sense of imperial
responsibility before God for
the behavior of the emperor's
subjects.
But already, a few years
later in 806, this
idea has been weakened.
In eighteen 806--
if you take a look at the first
map that I've given out,
we have a partition in 806, an
agreement at a place called
Thionville.
I guess this is going to have
to be spelled out, since we
don't have chalk.
T-H-I-O-N-V-I-L-L-E. And it's
written on the first-- well,
no it just says, proposed
partition.
In 806, he came up with the
idea of dividing his realm
among his three children.
His son Charles would get the
north, his son Pepin would get
Lombardy and Bavaria,
and his son
Louis would have Aquitaine.
In this document, there's no
mention of the imperial title,
leading one to surmise that
maybe he thought this title
was just his personal
accomplishment.
Maybe he didn't really envisage
the reestablishment
of the Roman Empire in any
kind of permanent way.
Here, we just have a kind
of splitting up of land.
Louis gets the southwest;
Charles gets the lion's share,
the heartlands of the
Carolingian family, the parts
of Germany that the Carolingians
controlled and
northern France; and Pepin
gets Italy and the Alps.
So here you have a contrast
between 802, this grandiose
imperial idea of unity, 806,
just like the Merovingians,
partitioning out the lands for
the successors of Charlemagne.
Aachen is a long way from
being another Byzantium
Constantinople or
another Baghdad.
And in these capitularies, the
documents that are issued by
the court of instructions to the
administrators, we do see,
as Fichtenau emphasizes, a
sense of unease and of
problems. Again and again,
the capitularies lament
corruption, maladministration.
They start to mention the
Vikings as more than just a
minor, mosquito-bite-level
distraction.
But most of all, they emphasize
usurpation of royal authority.
Usurpation meaning, again, that
the people, such as the
counts or dukes or the nobles
who are supposed to be
servants of the crown, supposed
to be his chief
servants, are taking over for
themselves things like taxes,
revenues, the right
of judgment, the
right to punish people.
And people are tending to look
at them as their rulers.
The count of Flanders, the count
of Barcelona, the duke
of Aquitaine, these are people
who are starting to think of
themselves as potentially, at
least, rulers who might
transmit their office
to their children.
And it then is not an office,
it's a possession, if you have
a right of inheritance.
In other words, I could transmit
to my children my
ten-year-old car, my silver
butter dish, all of my
treasured possessions, but I
cannot transmit to them the
professorship that I have. I
can't just say, well, my
eldest son is going to be a
professor of medieval history
at Yale, whether or not he has
any interest in doing that,
because I don't own
the position.
It's not my property.
It is my office.
We're so familiar with this that
we don't even think about
what it would be like.
Well, we actually do, because
there are some things that
people do tend to start to own
that, originally, were not
supposed to be that way.
But in the medieval world, it
is a problem to dislodge
people from property, because
most property is in land.
All Yale has to do is stop
paying me, and I'm no longer
benefiting from this office.
On the other hand, if I had
a castle across campus and
stored some boiling pitch and
some followers, naturally,
some trusty drinking mates, and
had this a little moat and
bailey establishment right
outside of Harkness, I could
terrorize Yale and
extort from it.
That picture is not
so far-fetched.
Where the picture is really
not far-fetched is if you
imagine Yale in ruins.
People pasturing sheep on Cross
Campus and wondering
"God, what were those
buildings, anyway?
They're really huge.
And all those funny little
blackboards, whatever they
were for." And then using WLH
to build fortifications.
Why build a new castle on the
lawn when you've got building
materials that somebody
else left for you?
So WLH 117, 116, 115 are
one person's fortress.
And that auditorium at the other
end is somebody else's.
And here I'm getting a little
bit ahead of myself, but this
is what's going to happen once
the Carolingian Empire
dissolves, essentially.
When I say to people usurp or
arrogate or make hereditary
their possessions,
I'm talking about
something that sounds abstract.
But if you think of it in terms
of what it means to defy
people, basically,
you're talking
about building castles.
And this has to do with
the nature of warfare.
This is all a subject for the
course that succeeds this one,
but it has to do with the nature
of warfare, in the
sense that, once you have that
castle, it's very hard to be
dislodged from it.
The advantage is with
the defense.
Catapults, trebuchets, all these
interesting weapons,
actually, both require an insane
amount of mobilization
and organization and are not as
effective as artillery some
centuries later is
going to be.
So the problems of Charlemagne's
empire--
despite the invasions that will
be our subject for Monday
after Thanksgiving--
the problems of Charlemagne's
empire are essentially
internal, as was the case of the
Roman Empire, only moreso.
These internal problems, what
I've called the lack of
infrastructure, which means
political and economic
infrastructure, make it very
difficult, effectively, to
resist the Vikings.
And there are other invaders
whom we'll have to mention as
well, later on, the Hungarians
and invaders and raiders from
North Africa.
The empire was too large,
given the nature of
communications and
the mechanisms
available to impose order.
The same thing that made it an
empire made it have some
disadvantages: diversity of
population, ethnic loyalties.
So you have revolts of
Aquitainians who are not
Franks; of Bretons, people of
Britanny, who are not Franks;
Bavarians; Visigoths.
All of these people are not
necessarily overjoyed with
Frankish rule, not necessarily
immune from the possibility of
seizing on the weakness of
the Franks to rebel.
These problems become more
manifest in the reign of
Charlemagne's son, Louis
the Pious, who
rules from 814 to 840.
My hesitation in using the
word rules is that he is
deposed once and forced to
undergo public penance twice.
One of the problems of the
empire was obviated, however.
When Charlemagne died in 814,
the succession was just to
Louis because his brothers
had died.
So the 806 deal, or
806 plan, was not
implemented and became moot.
Charlemagne was succeeded by one
sole ruler over the entire
empire, Louis the Pious,
because Pepin
and Charles had died.
Louis is often seen as inept
but well-meaning.
His sobriquet--
and a lot of the Carolingian
rulers now have
less-flattering than Pious
Charles the Bald, well, that
seems a little unfair.
Charles the Simple, Charles the
Fat, Louis the Stammerer,
Louis the Child.
You get the idea.
Not an imposing group
of rulers.
But pious, shouldn't pious
be a complement?
And indeed, it could be.
And, as it happens, he's not
known as Louis the Pious in
every language.
So in German, he's referred to
as Louis the Pious, but in
French, he's Louis the Debonair,
the Imposing.
He is an imposing figure,
actually.
He's not as weak as what I'm
going to say in the rest of
the discussion about him is
going to make him look.
He was a very effective
general.
He did a lot of wars
in southern France.
He was the effective
ruler of Aquitaine.
He conquered Barcelona
for Charlemagne.
He suffered from three
problems, however.
One not at all of his own
making, the second certainly
exacerbated by his vacillation,
and the third is
just who he was.
The first problem is
the invasions.
The Viking invasions, in
particular, begin during his
reign, first part of
the ninth century.
So it's an external problem.
On the other hand, the lack of
an effective response does
have to do with flaws in the
nature of Carolingian rule,
flaws in the nature of Louis'
rule, in particular.
The second problem
is his sons.
His sons fought against
each other and
against their father.
This is not something
that's new to us.
We've seen this with
the Merovingians.
But in order to maintain control
of sons who expect
some kind of rulership and who
are jockeying for power with
their siblings, Louis made it
worse, in part, because he had
sons by two marriages and tried
to carve out another
realm for his youngest son,
Charles the Bald, Charles the
future the Bald.
I don't know that he was called
Charles the Bald when
he was fourteen.
I actually don't know when
that title starts
to come into effect.
Not title, nickname.
As we'll see, these civil wars
have greater significance than
mere civil wars, because they're
at the origins of the
breaking up of the empire into
entities that we can just
about start to call France
and Germany.
So we're at the kind of
crucible, or moment of
creation, of the European order
that will exist for the
next more than 1,000 years.
Louis had very sophisticated
ideas about imperial rule.
Perhaps even more sophisticated
than those of
his father, because Louis was
quite a bit more educated than
Charlemagne, quite literate,
one might almost say an
intellectual as well as
an effective general.
But he was less pragmatic, less
realistic, less flexible
than his father.
Even more than Charlemagne,
Louis believed that the
emperor must answer before God
for the conduct of his
population.
Even more than Charlemagne, he
believed that he ruled over a
sanctified state.
In other words, he was not just
a political ruler, he
was, in some sense, a religious
leader that the
religious and the political were
not to be distinguished.
If the state is a religious
entity, does it mean that the
state rules over the Church?
Or if it's a religious entity,
perhaps it means that the
Church rules over the state?
It can go either way.
When Charlemagne was crowned
by the pope, he certainly
indicated a conception
of rulership
sanctified by the Church.
He was not at all worried
about the pope
dictating to him.
He had rescued the pope
from the Roman mob.
The pope was utterly
dependent on him.
But that is not necessarily
the way things would be.
And Louis had less to worry
about from the popes than from
his own bishops.
Taking his rulership as a sacred
trust seriously meant
that, in 822, he appeared at
a place called Attigny.
A-T-T-I-G-N-Y, Attigny.
In the Church of Attigny,
covered with ashes and dressed
in sack cloth, which the Bible
describes, and which, I guess,
burlap would be the best modern
equivalent, so dressed
in rags, literally, covered with
ashes to ask forgiveness
for the way in which the
rebellion of his nephew,
Bernard, had been suppressed.
Not only were his son's
restless, but his nephew had
rebelled, been captured,
been blinded, and died.
The blinding--
maybe they knew how to do
it better in Byzantium--
was supposed to be a more humane
alternative, rendering
him unfit to rule but
sparing his life.
But, in the end, he died.
Louis was full of remorse
for this and did a
public act of penance.
And we know from the experience
of all forms of
leadership, including modern,
that there are ways of saying
you're sorry and ways of not
saying you're sorry.
The problem with a political
officer or ruler saying they
are sorry is that it may
make them look weak.
It may make them lose their
aura of leadership.
The problem with them not saying
they're sorry, in the
modern world, of course,
is also very great.
And it's very tricky to
negotiate a line that
preserves command but also
gives, at least, the
impression of candor.
Louis does not have
Charlemagne's instinctive
charisma of leadership.
The penance at Attigny resulted
in his loss of
prestige and a great increase
in the power of the Church.
So there had always been an
implicit danger of this once
Frankish and Christian ideas
of rulership were merged.
Charlemagne, as I've said,
had no problem with
this, but Louis did.
Already in 829, Pope Gregory
IV would claim, "is not the
authority over souls, which
belongs to the pope, above the
imperial rule, which is of this
world?" The implication
here is that because the
spiritual is superior to the
material, in moral terms. And
why is the spiritual superior
to the material?
This is a sort of Plato's
Republic kind of question.
I'm just saying this--
Yes?
STUDENT: It's morality over
the pressures of lust or
something like that.
PROFESSOR: And not
merely morality over the
pleasures of lust. What's the
problem with the pleasures of
lust, from the killjoy, Plato's
Republic point of view?
STUDENT: They end.
PROFESSOR:
They end.
Right.
They are mortal.
They die.
And so is all matter,
by definition.
All matter fades.
So which is superior, the
spiritual or the material?
The spiritual doesn't die.
The spiritual is immortal.
That's what makes
it spiritual.
That's what the Forms, or
reality, or the higher, the
invisible, invisible-but-real.
To put ourselves in the mindset
of 829, of course we
have to admit that.
You may not feel that.
I'm not urging this upon
you as a world view.
You may think that there is no
such thing as the spiritual.
Or you may think that
the spiritual is as
mortal as the material.
But in 829, people would
agree, "Yeah, OK, the
spiritual is superior to the
material, because it's
immortal and the material
withers and dies." But does
that mean that the spiritual has
got to rule the material?
That's the question for the
ages, at least for the
medieval ages.
So Louis the Pious
and his sons.
In 817, Louis issues an order,
map number B, to divvy up the
realm in the event of his death,
an order called the
ordinatio imperii, the ordering
of the empire.
This, unlike Charlemagne's
division, really expresses an
idea of imperial rule.
Louis associates with himself
his eldest son, Lothar.
And look at how big their
territory is.
First of all, it's huge.
It encompasses the Carolingian
ancestral lands.
And basically, the other sons,
Louis the German, Bernard, and
Pepin, are given a bunch
of adjunct lands.
And in fact--I'm sorry.
Bernard is not his son.
It's his nephew.
And this is what Bernard rebels
against-- the rebellion
that will cause his blinding
and death--
is this, what he regarded as a
few crumbs from the table,
rather than a full share.
The real problem begins,
however, even after Attigny in
825 when Louis' second wife
gave birth to a son named
Charles, thus complicating
the succession.
His second wife, Judith, urged
him to fit Charles into the
succession, and this enraged
the older sons
from his first marriage.
In a 829, a council
met at Paris.
And while Charles was given a
share, the bishops of the
realm also claimed a right
to judge the king by his
performance.
In 831, a rebellion, a second or
third rebellion, broke out.
The sons of Louis the Pious,
although fighting against each
other, allied.
The Church regarded Louis,
now, as hopelessly
ineffectual, incapable of
bringing order to the realm.
And Louis was captured by his
sons, forced to abdicate both
by the Church and by Lothar
and Louis, his older sons.
Lothar was so arrogant, however,
that by 834 Louis had
been restored.
I won't go into the complexities
of this.
Suffice it to say that the
hapless, or at least unlucky,
Louis the Pious, when he died
in 840, provoked another war
of succession among his sons.
Keep in mind that, meanwhile,
the administration of the
empire is dissolving, and the
Viking invasions are occupying
ever more attention, ineffectual
attention, and
plundering even more.
After a series of battles and
campaigns, in 843, a third
partition took place.
But this one is really
important.
This is the Treaty of Verdun,
V-E-R-D-U-N. And that's the
third one on your map that
I have bold or, at least,
felt-tipped lines showing
the division.
And then, on page two of the
handout, on the upper part, is
the division of Verdun.
The Treaty of Verdun divided
the empire among the three
sons of Louis the Pious,
three surviving sons.
The western part went
to Charles the Bald.
And you see that in
white, Neustria,
Aquitaine, Spanish March.
It is what can start to
be called France.
The eastern part, which
is the darkest--
Saxony, eastern Austrasia,
Alemania, Bavaria--
went to Louis son, Louis,
also named Louis.
Louis the German, as he's
known to historians.
And he's known as Louis the
German in part because his
sphere of influence was the
East, which we can start to
call Germany.
The eldest son, Lothar, got
the middle part, which
stretches from what's now
the northern part of the
Netherlands, Frisia, all the way
down to Rome, and even a
little south of Rome, Spoleto.
This is the most prestigious
and, in some ways, richest
part of the Empire.
It has Aachen, the imperial
capital, and it has Rome, the
old imperial capital.
It has the lands of the
Carolingians, most of them, in
the region of Aachen, in the
region of the Low Countries,
modern Belgium.
What's the problem
with this realm?
Or what's the obvious military,
political problems?
Spence?
STUDENT: The shape would be
exceedingly hard to defend.
PROFESSOR: It
would be very hard to defend.
It would be easy to cut
off and invade.
And if we say that the western
part is France and we say that
the eastern part is Germany,
using these terms
anachronistically but not
inaccurately, what is the
middle part?
The middle part is all that part
of Europe that has been
fought over.
All of World War I
[correction: that]
takes place on the
Western Front.
Most of it takes place
in the northern
part of realm of Lothar.
The places where, like Belgium,
which this day, now,
is bitterly divided between
French-speaking and
Flemish-speaking.
In other words, people who speak
a Germanic language,
descended from some ancestral
Germanic language, and those
who speak French, descended
from Latin.
That line runs right
through Belgium.
And the same ambiguity pursues
this whole realm of Lothar's
down into Switzerland, a modern
polity-- well, modern,
late medieval and modern--
where they speak four official
languages and are so unsure
about which is the official one
that their stamps give the
name of the country in Latin
and their airline gives its
name in English.
Their stamps call themselves
Helvetia.
There has not been an entity
called that, really, in real
life terms, since the
Roman Empire.
But that's better than having
all four language on there.
It's more convenient.
So there's a linguistic
ambiguity, there's a cultural
ambiguity, and there's a
political ambiguity.
Because, of course, the
realm of Lothar didn't
hold up very long.
Its strategic flaw was very
quickly manifested.
It was divided, but
never permanently.
Part of this realm would be
called what in French is
Lorraine but in German
is called Lothringen.
Lothringen named after Lothar,
L-O-T-H-R-I-N-G-E-N. Alsace
and Lorraine, these two
provinces, are now France.
In 1870, they were
taken by Germany.
After World War I, they were
taken back by France.
Under Hitler, they became
annexed to Germany.
After World War II, they're
back with France.
A substantial proportion of the
population of Alsace still
speaks German.
And until about the seventy,
eighty years ago, a fairly
significant proportion of
Lorraine did as well.
The same kind of ambiguity as to
what are these territories.
And in our world, they either
are neither France nor
Germany-- hence, Belgium,
Netherlands, Switzerland--
or they've traded hands.
It is not exactly accurate to
say that the political,
military history of Europe
since 843 is simply the
unwinding of the consequences
of the Treaty of Verdun.
But it's not completely
inaccurate to say that either.
That doesn't mean that events
like the Reformation or the
second world war don't have
significance well beyond that.
But just in terms of border
shifting and maps of Europe,
the legacy of Verdun
is tremendous.
If the legacy of Charlemagne
is, in some sense, the
creation of a cultural realm
that can be referred to as
Europe, the legacy of the sons
of Louis the Pious is the
ambiguous division
of that realm.
What this really means, then, in
ninth century terms-- since
nobody said, wow, we're signing
the Treaty of Verdun.
This is going to have
consequences for centuries--
the immediate consequences were
the decreasing relevance,
the decreasing importance,
of the imperial title.
When Lothar died and his eldest
son died soon after,
Lothar's realm was divided
between Louis and Charles.
Then, Italy was left to
a son of Lothar's
called Louis the Second.
He took on the imperial title.
But under Charles the Bald, the
third and much youngest
son of Louis the Pious,
for a little while
the Empire was reunited.
For a little while meaning,
basically, two years.
When Charles died in 877,
the Empire would not be
reestablished as unified
for almost a century.
And when it was, it would really
consist of, basically,
an enlarged Germany and a
portion of Italy, not France.
And Charles, although he bore,
between 875 and 877, the grand
title of emperor and was
unchallenged within his own
family, his rulership was
already severely undermined by
the intrigues of his nobles
and the Vikings.
By the time of his death, many
of the counties that had
originally been administrative
divisions of the Empire has
become almost independent.
So for example, Barcelona,
conquered by Louis the Pious,
was now ruled after 868 by
a count who paid nominal
allegiance to the ruler of the
western kingdom, but who was
the founder of a dynasty.
Up to 868, therefore, you have
counts of Barcelona who are
appointed by the ruler.
After 868, the ruler has very
little to do with it.
It is a local ruler.
And the count is no longer an
office holder but a ruler in
his own right.
Similar with Aquitaine.
Similar with Bavaria.
Similar with Poitou,
Toulouse, Flanders.
The reason that the counts are
able to do this is the
weakness of the central power,
not only because of the
personality of the ruler, but
because of the inadequate
nature of the administration.
When Charles died, he was
succeeded by several rulers in
the West: Louis the Stammerer,
Louis the Third, who had the
good fortune of just being Louis
the Third; and Carloman
In Germany, the ruler
was Charles the Fat.
And he was elected is emperor
for, again, four years, but
was pretty utterly
ineffectual.
And not because he was
fat, I hasten to add.
The Middle Ages did not share
our prejudices in this regard.
So Louis the Fat, in the twelfth
century, was a very
effective king.
Fat or not, Charles, this
particular Charles was not an
effective ruler.
All of these rulers, as
I said, suffered the
depredations of the Vikings.
But once again, I want to
emphasize that the problems of
this empire, or the problems
of these separate kingdoms,
or, indeed, the problems of some
of the counties ruled by
independent counts but affected
by the Vikings and
other invaders, were internal.
The Vikings were opportunistic
raiders, not the cause of the
dissolution of authority.
The dissolution of authority
didn't mean that the
Carolingians come to an end.
Because by this time, in the
late ninth century, they have
some of the prestige that
the Merovingians
had in their decline.
In their veins flowed the
blood of Charlemagne.
They were a sacred dynasty.
They had a certain
kind of prestige.
So for example, they would be
kings of France, with some
minor interruption, until 987.
In Germany, the family ends in
911, and a new series of
dynasties comes into effect.
In 987, a new dynasty comes into
rule of France called the
Capetian dynasty,
C-A-P-E-T-I-A-N, which
technically runs out in 1314,
fourteen but which is related
to the French kings since.
And indeed, when Louis the XVI
was guillotined by the French
Revolution, he was referred to
in the court documents as
"Louis Capet." In other words,
they gave him a kind of
artificial last name and regard
him as descended from
this ruler Hugh Capet,
C-A-P-E-T. Thus, a member of
the Capetian, C-A-P-E-T-I-A-N,
dynasty.
But the reality of France, and
even of Germany, in the 10th
century would be as a series
of nearly independent
principalities feuding,
only nominally
controlled by the kings.
The ruler, Hugh Capet, who
succeeded in 987, basically,
he seems to have controlled
the road
between Paris and Orleans.
But in places that are now
public parks in Paris, like
Vincennes, there were castles
not loyal to the king at all.
So my little fantasy of a
fortified Cross Campus is not
so far-fetched, at least not
so far-fetched in terms of
what really happened in places
like Paris, and indeed in, for
example, the city of Arles in
southern France, there's a
wonderfully preserved Roman
stadium, Roman sports arena
that was fortified.
That is, one family had the
bleachers and fought against
the people who had the boxes
behind home plate.
Not a classical term, but behind
what might have been
considered home plate,
anachronistically.
And indeed, there are towers
built on top of this structure
that were then demolished,
because they were medieval and
not classical.
But they made use of
these materials.
So we have a society in which
the power of the ruler has
literally dissolved.
Not dissolved into water, but
certainly crumble into much
smaller components.
Those components being,
essentially, a castle, or a
few castles, the territory
around it, the right to
exploit the peasants
around it.
Maybe you would have an
effective regional ruler, like
the count of Barcelona or the
Count of Flanders, who would
tie to himself these castellans,
the people who own
or run the castle.
But it is a society that
has become fragmented.
It's not a barbarian society.
These are not nomads.
They're violent, but then again,
lots of societies run
on violence.
It's a controlled kind
of violence.
They want to squeeze the
peasants, even occasionally,
perhaps, plunder them.
They don't want to have them go
away or exterminate them,
because they don't have
any wealth otherwise.
It is an exploitative society.
But that, again, is not entirely
new or entirely
unknown in other historical
periods and places.
What it does bring up, however,
and which I'll try to
address in our last class once
we've talked about the
Vikings, is what's been
accomplished.
Here we are, from 300 AD to the
year 1000, and we're still
talking about invasions.
And we're still talking about
polities falling apart because
they're too large.
We're still talking about the
lack of administrative control
over powerful individuals.
So I promise you that something
was accomplished.
And I will try to describe
that next time.
But you're forgiven for thinking
that that, perhaps,
we have wandered around
and not come very far.
Have a very good Thanksgiving,
and I'll see you soon.